hallo mein Name ist Luca und
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht warum
ich dieses Video gemacht habe einiger
Zeit habe ich mein Frühstück was ich
immer esse in meine Instagram Story
gepostet und extrem viele und das hat
mich sehr doll gewundert von euch haben
mir geschrieben
was ist das und eigentlich hat man es
auf dem Story Bild ziemlich gut erkannt
aber da ja eine Dummheit dachte ich mir
ich zeig's euch jetzt tatsächlich mal
viele konnten nämlich nicht glauben dass
mein Frühstück was ich morgen schon esse
2000 Kalorien hat weil ihr wisst ihr
dass ich aktuell so ein bisschen mäßig
auf dem Fitness Trip bin dementsprechend
ist Frühstück das wie sagt man das
Gottes
genau morgens wie ein Kaiser mittags wie
ein König und abends wie ein Bettler so
grundsätzlich bestimmt mein Frühstück
aus zwei Teilen und zwar einmal brotten
mit allen möglichen Krams drauf und
einem Shake den ich mir frisch
zubereitet generell an alle Leute die
sonst Koch konnte bei anderen Youtubern
schauen ich ähm bin kein Koch ich koche
relativ selten
coole Fahrrad
zunächst einmal benutze ich als
Grundlage dass Harry anno 1688
Dinkelbrot
ist kein placement aber das war halt
einfach gerade im
angeschreiben allerdings nur zwei mein
Toaster weil mein Toaster nur Platz für
zwei ich bin aber auch noch Platz für
zwei Scheiben weil wenn die beiden
Scheiben fertig sind kannst du diese
Scheiben belegen in der Zwischenzeit
gehen die anderen beiden Scheiben rein
hast du gefragt nein Digger während
diese beiden Scheiben die passen nicht
mehr den Toaster rein
während diese beiden Scheiben auf jeden
Fall im Toaster einen kleinen Saunagang
zu sich nehmen würde ich sagen nehmen
wir unser Olivenöl
das ist auch kein besonderes Olivenöl
das ist einfach das einzige was in meine
Schublade dabei ist wir nehmen unser
Olivenöl klatschen ist in die Pfanne und
äh packen dort von mir bereits
präparierte Hähnchenbrustfilets rein das
wird jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal
gesalzen
Paprika Gewürz dran und Brathähnchen
Gewürze Salz ich weiß das jetzt
wahrscheinlich so ein Gordon Ramsay sich
so eine eigene Gewürzmischung
zusammenstellen würde aus zu frischen
keine Ahnung Thymian oder jeder
brennende nee
es gibt so geile Gewürze einfach so
kaufen kann keine Ahnung ich habe halt
irgendwie wir nehmen uns jetzt auf jeden
Fall einen großen Teller weil es gibt
auch ein großes Frühstück und klatschen
dazu allererst schon mal die beiden
rotscheiben drauf
feucht von der einen Seite während unser
chicken jetzt auf jeden Fall noch zu
Ende Brett nehmen wir unsere
schneiden die auf und machen ohne das
Andere vielleicht schneiden wird und
dann auch wieder mit Mörser bitte dann
drüber mit Prise Salz aus dem Orient
aber
ihr werdet gleich aussehen wenn ich es
vorher mache ich mache es ein bisschen
Zeit sparen darf das riecht auf jeden
Fall schon gut danke Bruder
viele Küchengeräte mit dem man das hier
irgendwie besser machen kann da
irgendwie wie heißt dieses Dings
170 g Hähnchen 147 Gramm Avocado wir
werden jetzt noch die dritte Scheibe
Brot hier reinpacken ich könnte zwar
zwei reinpacken aber das wäre dann schon
sehr sehr viel zu essen in der Zeit wo
diese Brotscheibe jetzt auf jeden Fall
noch am chillen ist machen wir jetzt
einmal schneiden wir unsere Eier auf
jetzt ein bisschen
[Musik]
Salz
in die
noch ein bisschen Pfeffer in die Eier
mit rein
wir hauen jetzt auf jeden Fall Zwiebeln
ja es sind schon diese Pre geschnittenen
Zwiebeln aus dem Supermarkt von
Iglo aber ich habe einfach keinen Bock
der Zwiebel zu schneiden weil danach
stinkende Fingernägel den ganzen Tag und
muss nicht schmecken muss und dann
schneiden wir auch noch Tomaten auf ich
weiß das ist 1000 einfachere
Wege und lifehacks gibt die man ganz
viele Tomaten auf einmal schneiden kann
von Emrah diesen Trick damals oder zwei
was macht Emre eigentlich der damals
einfach zwei Teller genommen
dazwischen und einmal mit dem Messer
hergestellt ich habe das auch probiert
mit so einem Finger geschnitten dass ich
irgendwie zwei Wochen langsam Verband
tragen musste deswegen wir machen es
ganz entspannt ne während das ganze
jetzt allerdings kurz an dreht haben wir
Zeit um entweder die Küche schon mal ein
bisschen aufzuräumen oder um uns die
Brötchen schon äh die
dementsprechend nehmen wir zuallererst
in der Margarine weil meine Ansicht nach
Margarine gehört auch alle egal ob
Marmelade egal ob Nutella egal auch hier
und wakamole kommt auch noch drauf aber
Margarine gehört auf alles was irgendwie
mit Brot oder Brötchen zu tun hat wir
sehen jetzt hier schon dass die
Cherrytomaten so leicht matschig werden
das ist nämlich das perfekte Zeichen
indem wir dann die Eier mit dazugeben
allerdings genau in diesem Moment wo wir
die Eier reingeben auch die Stufe auf
Mittel stellen
krasse ich habe jetzt ein Kameramann
gefragt hat wahrscheinlich gibt's auch
richtig coole Werkzeuge um das halt auch
da irgendwie cool drauf zu legen aber
ich nehme einfach immer Finger scheiße
drauf das hier ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
der erste Teil meines Frühstücks also
wirklich das Essen bestehend aus drei
Broten Margarine drauf Guacamole
Hähnchenbrustfilet und Eier mit Tomaten
und Zwiebeln es sieht einfach aus wie so
Matschepampe aber ich schwöre euch es
schmeckt sehr sehr wild und der zweite
Teil meines Frühstücks hatte eingangs
schon erwähnt besteht aus einem Shake
der geht wirklich extrem schnell und
besteht aus 7 Bestandteilen deswegen
füllen wir jetzt erstmal knapp 500 ml
Milch da rein also ich nutze so eine
Hafermilch weil normale Milch kann das
keine Ahnung kriege ich irgendwie seit 9
Jahren schon nicht mehr und 109 Gramm
Banane also einfach eine Banane rein
dann noch zehn Gramm Leinöl aber das ist
ähm halt Google einfach ich will jetzt
nicht zu jedem Produkt was sagen wenn
man keine Zeit dafür ein so ein
Esslöffel Mandeln muss das sind glaube
ich so 20 Gramm oder so dann packen wir
noch Bären rein ich habe eine Zeit lang
frische Beeren reingepackt aber dann
habe ich die einmal gekauft und dann war
Schimmel drin in dieser Packung seitdem
hole ich mal diese Tiefkühlen Grundlage
Shakes Haferflocken
auch einfach die billigsten dieser
gehabt so eine Packung kostet 79 Cent
also
ihr merkt schon das ist jetzt hier kein
krankes kochvideo wir nehmen Tomaten aus
Italien nehmen wir nehmen Zwiebeln aus
keine Ahnung
Flocken vom Mond sondern einfach nur das
was das was passt Haferflocken und das
Allerletzte was ich noch mal rein mache
ist so ein Weight Game Pulver davon auch
einfach so ein bisschen was rein
meistens so 35 Gramm 28 Jahre 28
wir nehmen jetzt auf jeden Fall unseren
Smoothie und schütten hier rein ihr seht
schon jetzt nicht komplett flüssig aber
auch nicht komplett dick also man kann
ihn auf jeden Fall entspannt trinken und
den ziehen wir uns jetzt natürlich nicht
zum Frühstück komplett rein sondern ich
trinke immer so die Hälfte davon während
ich das äh die Brote esse die andere
Hälfte dann wenn ich dann am PC bin oder
keine Ahnung was du in der Stunde danach
und ja das hier ist jetzt tatsächlich
mein Frühstück nachdem so viele von euch
gefragt hatten wirklich einfach drei
Brote Margarine Guacamole
Hähnchenbrustfilet gebraten drauf und
dann Rührei mit Tomaten und Zwiebeln
drin und im Shaker halt einfach
Hafermilch Mandelmus Leinöl
Haferflocken Banane Bären und ein
scubategor alles in allem sind wir jetzt
hier bei
2242 Kilokalorien und alles mögliche an
Nährwerten und keine Ahnung was blende
ich euch jetzt hier mal ein also es ist
eigentlich echt sehr sehr sehr geiles
Frühstück wenn man zumindestmasse
Muskeln aufbauen möchte deswegen guten
Appetit ich hoffe euch hat das Video
gefallen hat dann lasst gerne einen
Daumen hoch runter runter abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
weiter Videos nichts verpassen den Test
[Musik]
na gut ich muss jetzt halt sagen dass
das über krass schmeckt und wenn ihr das
hier nicht kochen wollt dieser Shake
alleine hat irgendwie schon 1000
Kalorien der schmeckt so brutal der
schmeckt richtig lecker und da sind so
Haferflocken drin blablabla das ist
richtig gut wenn irgendwie meine
Mahlzeit verpasst oder bevor irgendwie
Fast Food bestellt oder so macht euch
diesen Shake das geht so schnell
schmeckt so lecker aber gut ich lasse
euch jetzt in Ruhe sorry dass ich jetzt
hier mal ein kochvideo gemacht habe wird
doch das letzte diese mehr bleiben